hi everyone this is inio and space jam
needs no introduction it's a classical
96 if you haven't watched it please go
do yourself a favor
we have jason freeny's hidden
dissectables collectibles thank you so
much mikeyjacks for sending this over we
can get bugs bunny lola bunny daffy duck
come off in the martian mrs swag camera
blanco and tasmanian devil but the thing
is he's a rare character so things we
may or may not get him but we'll see
what we can get they're all blind boxes
so let's just open this up
all right now that we're nice and set up
down here you know the pop-up is really
great you know that i just showed every
character you can get so let's just get
to unboxing
let's get the first one out
all right
okay so in each one you get a base down
here
per character
all right
so you see that it's verified
and also it comes with instructions on
how to verify your product so we'll just
leave that one side and this is the
trading card that comes with every
character but we'll open this last
let's just see
who we got
oh we got blanco
oh he's looking really cool
for the one star steam
all right let's put this one aside and
then we're just going to place him right
here
so obviously this is jason freeny's
signature design with all the
dissectable bits and everything and the
build quality just feels really good
it's all vinyl slash pvc figurines right
so the first character we got is
blanco
very nicely well done
it's a nice little card
right here
right let's put in one side
onto the next one i'm feeling that you
know the middle one more
okay same thing
yeah it's not tall character though it's
definitely not test i'm actually looking
up a test
and we got the man himself we got bugs
money down here
all right moving on
trading card
okay gotta put them right here next box
we're gonna go with the bottom right
let's see who this is
i think
you have no idea who this is
let's decide let's open it up
oh it's daffy duck
look at him
really nice coloring build quality solid
as well but yeah let's put them on
alongside
and
there we go
all right it's trading code
there you have it daffy duck all right
let's move on to the next
the last three
let's go with the middle again
oh this is a heavy one
i think it's just the sweat camo
yes it is with the swag ammo
wow this feels amazing it's got a bit of
weight to it it's quite hefty
real solid work here
here he is on the stand
i like this piece a lot
it's really nice and hefty
let's go to the left first then the
right
okay and i think
this might be
lola let's see if it's lola
and i'm right
it is lola
i'm getting the hang of this actually
yeah
look at it she's so cute
this is a really nice piece
all right let's get on the stand
there we go
lola bunny
okay let's put it here get the trading
card out
a little bunny
amazing i can't even got that right oh
and the last one
then this entire thing off i'm just
hoping his test i think that'd be tess
please let me test
are you in marvin martian i'm cool with
that
oh
[Applause]
i don't think it says i think it's
marvin
yeah it's marvin oh man
it's all good
look at him
these are some damn good-looking
figurines all right
i'm gonna stand
beautiful
look at that
and let's get his trading card out
[Music]
we got everyone but the tasmanian devil
but you know it's all good everyone
looks amazing and let's just
wrap this up
right so now the whole squad is here i
want to quickly run through how you guys
can actually verify
your figurines and add them into your
virtual collection on the mighty jax app
obviously the first thing you need to do
is to download the mighty jacks app and
from there go to your vault which is at
the bottom right
and then you can go and scan your toys
now the thing is we're actually looking
for the for real verified stickers at
the base so once it's scanned the first
time you need to go through a two-step
verification process to guarantee the
product's authenticity let's hit
continue
and let's tap the nfc text again
so once you're done with that you
basically just verified the ownership of
the figurine all right and that pretty
much wraps up the video these are
beautiful figurines thank you again
mighty jax for sending this box to us
you guys are real g's if you guys have
any questions about these figurines let
us know in the comment section down
below we will do our best to answer them
for you and let us know if you're gonna
get a box for yourself and with that
don't forget to follow us on all of our
socials right here like this video and
subscribe to us we have a ton of content
coming your way
this is zinio signing off
[Music]